الى افغانستان الان وهناك يتراقب
المتابعون ما اذا كانت حكومه طالبان
ستتراجع عن القيود التي فرضتها على
الفتيات الرغبات في التعلم مع اعاده فتح
المدارس الثانويه الشهر المقبل وبعد 550
يوما من اجبار الفتيات على البقاء في
المنزل يضع تقرير لصحيفه تايمز املا في
اخر النفق الذي بداته طالبان بتصعيدها ضد
المراه تدريجيا منذ الاطلاع على الحكم في
اغسطس من سنه 2021 فلم يقتصر الامر على
منع الفتيات من الالتحاق بالمدارس
المتوسطه والثانويه اذ امتد ليشمل
الجامعات وحظرهن من المجيء الى الصلاه
الرياضيه والحدائق العامه فضلا عن منعهن
من السفر بدون مرافقه الذكور ترى التايمز
البريطانيه ان الانقسامات غير المسبوقه
كما وصفتها بين قياده طالبان بشان حظر
تعليم الفتيات اثار بعض الامل في التغيير
هذه الامال
بافكار زعيم الحركه او تصطدم بافكار زعيم
الحركه هبه الله اخ زاده التي تصفه
الصحيفه بالرجل الغامض حيث يرى بحسب خبراء
ان منحى النساء حقوقهن سوف يقوض سلطه
جماعته وتختلف طالبان التي يقودها خنسادا
عن تلك التي اعتلت السلطه في التسعينات
بقياده زعيمها ومؤسسها الراحل محمد عمر
حيث تشهد الان وجود اجنحه وفصائل داخلها
فهناك المتشددون الذين يدعمهم زاد وثم
تفريق اخر اكثر برغماتيه تقول صحيفه ان
هناك املا في مقاومه ناعمه داخل الحركه
نفسها لقرارات زاد حيث يتم بالفعل تحدي
حظر التعليم بهدوء اذ يسمح قاده طالبان
المحليون بالمدارس المجتمعيه غير النظاميه
او يغطون الطرف عن المدارس السريه